think about the worst traffic that you
have ever sat in the most crowded bus
you've ever been on now multiply that by
10 that's what life is like in mega city
cities as big as entire countries there
are already more than 30 of them on the
planet and soon most of us will call
them home
the term mega cities describes a
continuous urban area of more than 10
million people so what's 10 million
people well think about it this way the
New York metropolitan area really a huge
place is ninth on the list with a
population of 20 millions Los Angeles
with 15 million is the 18th largest
London which was the first modern city
to have more than a million people
barely even makes the list and the
largest mega city today is the Tokyo
Yokohama area with a whopping thirty
seven point eight million people but
those places are about to be left behind
the biggest cities of the future are
places you might not expect Lagos
Nigeria is already home to more than 17
million people and growing about 50%
every decade by 2050 it'll likely at
least double in size rivaling tokey
China is already home to four mega
cities including Shenzhen the
manufacturing capital in 1979 when it
was only a fishing village Shenzhen had
fewer than 30,000 people today it has a
population of more than 15 million and
by 2050 it could be home to more than 50
million then there's Karachi Pakistan
which takes population growth to a whole
new level this mega city with fifteen
thousand five hundred people per square
mile is the third most dense in the
world behind Dhaka and Mumbai it's
already home to more than 23 million
people but as it creaks under the weight
of massive migration and a growing
average household size some estimates
say it'll have more than 53 million
people by 2050 that's bigger than all of
present-day South Korea how do these
cities get so big so fast well they tend
to have little areas nearby and people
leave those areas to earn more in the
city what we consider individual cities
today could merge
two single sprawling mega cities in the
future shenzhen could join with Hong
Kong and Gwangju to become one enormous
city with a population of 120 million
people that would make that single city
the same size as present-day Mexico and
larger than all that 11 countries today
so what will life be like in these
places well on the one hand there's
tremendous opportunity the top 25 mega
cities already account for more than
half the world's wealth but research
suggests that the bigger the city the
more unequal life is there mega cities
will likely reward the rich and educated
while punishing the poor with higher
rates of segregation crime and health
issues by 2050 it's estimated that seven
in ten of us will be living in one of
these magazines the question is at which
end of the spectrum will you be